uncharted 3 was important very important
and i'm going to tell you why
the year is 2011. gamers all over the
world are gushing over titles like
batman arkham city gears of war 3 and
the soon to be released elder scrolls 5
skyrim meanwhile a charismatic little
adventurer named nate is preparing to
make another big splash on sony's third
console but could that splash be bigger
than the one he made in 2009 november
1st 2021 marked the 10th anniversary of
uncharted 3 drake's deception and in the
decades since its release a lot has
changed naughty dog released the last of
us uncharted 4 uncharted lost legacy and
the last of us part 2 all of which
altered how we perceive the developer in
their own unique ways still uncharted 2
and 4 are widely held up as the best in
the series and for good reasons however
i'm here to tell you even though
uncharted 3 isn't the best it's the most
important for nate's development in this
video we're taking a look back at how
uncharted 3 lived up to its predecessor
what it did for the franchise and how it
holds up in a post uncharted 4 world for
more videos like this make sure to hit
the like button and subscribe to
gamespot
the 2009 spike video game award for game
of the year
goes to
uncharted 2 among themes
uncharted 2 among thieves was huge as
the title suggests it's the second
mainline game in the uncharted series
and received boatloads of critical
acclaim following its release in october
of 2009. nearly two years after
uncharted drake's fortune hit shelves
needless to say uncharted 2 is pretty
special and it stood as my favorite game
of all time until the witcher 3 and
breath of the wild came out but this
video isn't about link or geralt so
let's get back to nate just in case
you've never played an uncharted game
before let me summarize each game for
you in a very simple way
a man wants treasure so that man goes to
find the treasure but someone else wants
the treasure too so the man has to race
the other person to the treasure and
manages to defeat them just in the nick
of time it's a formula that doesn't
reinvent the wheel but it works as a
vehicle to drive the player to each new
string of fun dialogue and huge set
piece moments and uncharted 2 has both
of those elements in spades and most
importantly it doesn't include a jet ski
level
the success was without a doubt a great
thing for naughty dog but it also meant
that uncharted 3 had really big shoes to
fill so how could the dev keep this
momentum
going uncharted 3's development began in
2010 when for the first time naughty dog
split its dev team into two one team
worked on uncharted 3 while the other
worked on the last of us critically the
game reviewed very well grabbing a 9 out
of 10 from us here at gamespot and 10
out of 10 from sites like destructoid
and ign in terms of sales uncharted 3
blew past its predecessor and went on to
become the 4th best-selling ps3 game by
2015 the last of us being number 3 and
uncharted 2 being number 5. however
despite reviewing well and selling well
a quick google search will show you that
fan opinions of uncharted 3 are a bit
mixed some of this criticism includes
it's glitchy the hand-to-hand combat is
clunky it's more linear it's story makes
no sense and it's just more of the same
but i'd argue that not all of those
things are 100 true sure when you
compare the changes naughty dog made
from uncharted 1 to 2 with the changes
from 2-3 there isn't a whole lot to
speak of uncharted 2 improved gameplay
hand-to-hand combat grenade throwing
graphics added a little bit of stealth
elements as well as the grand spectacle
that was the cinematic cutscene like
gameplay moments but for what uncharted
3 lacks in terms of shiny new features
it makes up for with the story that
features nate looking more inward than
ever before if each entry boils down to
searching for treasure then uncharted 3
was the first to include the subtext of
nate searching for himself why is he
doing all of this what does he want
versus what does he need who is he
really it was the first game in the
series to give nate more of a backstory
and explain why he and sully put so much
trust in each other it stripped back
some of the campiness of the previous
two games and attempted to tell a
slightly more grounded story where the
characters could have important moments
like this one
i gotta say
i'm losing the plot here
remind me again why we're doing this
no no no no no if you're gearing up for
one of your i'm too old for this
speeches spare me
mate these guys are playing for keeps
yeah so
what you're just gonna roll over for
them nobody's talking about rolling over
then quit acting like you're ready to
lay down and die all right
listen kitten
i've had you back for 20 years
i'm not going anywhere
obviously
i just want to make sure we're doing
this for the right reasons
you got your pride all tangled up in
this thing it's making you reckless
i taught you better than that
the game's antagonist catherine marlow
isn't as threatening as some of the
others but she's a bit more calculated
and manipulative in the way she plays
with nate's head in a way she's like the
physical embodiment of nate's
consciousness
mind hell she even acts as his inner
voice later in the game after he loses
everything and wanders aimlessly through
the desert though my favorite line of
hers comes from her one-on-one talk with
nate where after poking the scars of his
past she plants a seed of distrust but
ask yourself
when he scooped you off the streets of
colombia 20 years ago
did he save you from that life
or did he just doom you to this one
and then there's elena possibly the most
important factor in nate's inner
struggle the story of uncharted 3 picks
up hot off the heels of nate and elena's
separation the two were married sometime
between the events of uc 2 and 3 but
things fell apart due to nate's lack of
commitment and lust for adventure this
conflict makes a return in uncharted 4
but it was here that we first got to see
the two clash in a different way than in
previous entries in uncharted 3 she's no
longer just elena begging him to hang it
up and walk away she's his estranged
wife asking him to decide what's more
important to him
what is wrong with you two elena come on
we're just joking around listen
you've won okay
you've outsmarted her
you know where to find the city and
marlow doesn't
why can't that be enough
[Music]
uncharted 3 may have felt like filler to
some and it might get slightly
overlooked because it sits between two
of the best in the series but without it
nate couldn't have become the man we see
in part 4.
so by now you're probably asking but
devante is it worth playing 10 years
later
yeah yeah it is even in a post uncharted
4 world with better graphics and tighter
gameplay uncharted 3 still manages to
shine the performances from nolan north
and the gang are rock solid making it
nearly impossible to not love these
characters the gameplay feels a little
rough in some spots such as the
hand-to-hand combat sequences the
wannabe stealth sections and the running
towards the camera stuff
but overall the complete package is just
as fun to play through as it ever was
and that's partly due to the game's
great level design which features series
gems like the chateau and the shipyard
these areas as well as the final escape
scene in the now classic plane moment
left me awestruck and eager for more but
it's not just the big moments that made
me feel like that it's also the calm
moments like getting to play as young
nate for the first time a moment that
wasn't really shown off in all of the
marketing and speaking of marketing
don't even get me started on uncharted
3's weird partnership with subway that
convinced me to go there way too many
times
subway where winners eat now it's crazy
to think about it but when uncharted 3
first released i was a 19 year old
college student dealing with keeping my
grades up and managing the heartbreak of
my crush being in love with my roommate
instead of me so sometimes my first
memories of the game can get a little
bit overshadowed by everything else i
was dealing with at the time however
when i put all of that aside i'm struck
with a sense of pride and nostalgia
pride because of how hard i worked to
pay for my ps3 so i wouldn't have to
borrow a friend's console like i'd done
with uncharted 2. and nostalgia because
the uncharted games meant so much to me
back then and still do to a certain
extent i can't even listen to the main
theme without getting a little
teary-eyed and just covered in
goosebumps
uncharted 3 drake's deception had some
big shoes to fill but it managed to live
up to those expectations by keeping
uncharted 2's award-winning formula and
putting nate through a transformative
experience it's hard to imagine nate's
journey without uncharted 3 and even 10
years later it's still a joy to play
thank you so much for watching i know
that this wasn't a ranked video but hit
the comment section and let me know how
you would rank the uncharted games and
feel free to include the mobile game or
golden abyss or even that trading card
game for vita yeah you remember that one
knock yourself out throw that into the
ranking and if you made it this far hit
the like button and subscribe so that
you know if and when uncharted 5 gets
announced
later
[Music]
you